eine frage die sich fragen was sie als
letztes verkauft haben heute einige
[Musik]
leute was geht und was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ich weiß nicht viele haben schon
mitbekommen ich sehe bisher ein bisschen
anders aus wenn ihr das video dazu noch
nicht gesehen habt schaut euch gerne an
ja ich musste meine haare schneiden wie
die person vor mir
oder der kunde vor mir es war ein rapper
ist auf jeden fall lustig geworden kann
ich nicht mehr empfehlen ist der video
verlinkt und auch am ende heute machen
wir aber was noch krassere cider ich
schicke das immer noch nicht bei dieser
kamera ich gucke immer oben dem
bildschirm obwohl ich wirklich schon so
lange youtube-videos mache und zwar
erwarte ich gerade noch auf den markt ja
mag brady wie kann ja wahrscheinlich die
meisten von euch der mit der mütze weil
das video machen leute zu 2 erscheint im
titel doch schon gelesen losgeht warten
jetzt aber erstmal auf mag und dann
erkläre ich denen die idee und dann
versteht ihr das auch alles und dann
fahren wir los und ich bin gespannt was
heute warum kommt ich habe bock
mal schauen und das ist natürlich auch
ich bin mal gespannt wie toll dass wir
über leute kann es wirklich extrem teuer
wären ja das ist ja ganz klar ich melde
mich wir sehen uns gleich mag es da nahm
es geht
war der ist schon laut so leute ja
zeigen weil deine sicherung lage sind
zurzeit gleich als sie habe aber absolut
nicht gewillt alles klappt einfach meine
idee geklaut aber so bin ich auch
gesehen gleich oder was weiß ich sie ein
bisschen besticht dabei durch werde man
sieht dadurch direkt viel aggressiver
jaja ich wirtschaft meine mutter du hast
doch welt geschickt wo deine mutter so
gesagt also aus die bushido meine mutter
hat wird von farid bang geschickt
das bild plötzlich über ein abkommen wir
gehen einfach kurz ins auto dann erklärt
ich noch mal was wir machen gefahr jetzt
zum apple store und eigentlich weiß es
ja auch schon so genau
bis gleich leute wir fahren jetzt zum
apple store ist erklärte noch mal kurz
wie video idee oder für alle es geht bei
diesen sachen immer darum dass wir das
gleiche kaufen wie die person form heute
machen wir aus dem apple store
ich bin mal gespannt was es wird und ob
das überhaupt klappt weil die gesagt
werden letztmals schon das problem viele
leute schauen halt nur einkaufen
linkspartei irgendjemand gibt es ja
etwas gewerkelt aber mal gucken wie
lange wir
da drin sind saturn war ich über eine
stunde wo ich das gemacht habe
ich hoffe du kriegst diesen macbook der
erst konfiguriert werden muss
1930 noch kurz sagen wollte und zwar
wurde ja letztes mal der fernsehen
verlost kann ich noch mal kurz einbinden
um ehrlich zu sein habe ich noch kein
gewinner ermittelt das mache ich dann
allerdings zu hause und blenden hier mit
einer kommentar ein
herzlichen glückwunsch du hast dem
fernseher gewonnen meld dich mal bei mir
und dann schicke ich dir den willen dazu
oder nicht dein name leute ganz kurz das
produkt was sie heute kaufen natürlich
auch am ende des videos verlost deswegen
ist es ganz ganz wichtig dass ihr dran
bleibt wie immer abonnent sein und euren
instagram nahm in die kommentare
schreiben oder eure e mail damit ich
erreichen kann weiter geld denkt die
ganze nicht so warum sie immer meine
haare nicht auf diesen kampf ja wir
sehen uns gleich danken gewalt oder
jetzt macht so asozial aus leute wir
sind angekommen
hier im apple store center und jetzt
geht's erst mal in den apple store und
dann schauen wir mal was es wird oder
ergo es war wie alles eingepackt hat er
hat sich gestern eine handvoll heime in
die kommentare hashtag ende mag so leute
bevor wir jetzt in den apple store gehen
haben wir uns noch etwas leckeres zu
trinken holt und zu essen
aber man muss auch was leckeres immer
sie da wünscht dir auf jeden fall einen
guten appetit
so leute wegen erstmal reinigen also
leute dass wir das wieder
nachsynchronisiert weil es sehr laut war
und ich das zusammengeschnitten habt
let's go hier sind wir reingegangen und
da waren wirklich sehr sehr sehr viele
leute wichtig ist ich fühle mich so
kriminell wenn wir so was war aber wir
haben hier hatten wir direkt jemanden
der sich für eine apple bot interessiert
hat da sind wir weitergegangen
wir haben ja noch beobachtet die haben
sich wirklich sehr darüber informiert
diese beiden diese drei leute wurden
beraten bezüglich airport wie
funktioniert das
ich glaube dass wir uns gedacht gut
haben wir mal zu was passiert da wird
die uhr verkauft und dann ist halt das
passiert
mag wo dann erstmals 20 minuten
bezüglich apple watches beraten hat am
ende dann natürlich keine körper nicht
an dass man so was auf die uhr geguckt
also 40 minuten waren schon warum das
sieht aus als werden wieder echt so weiß
sie also diese qualität echt heftig
manchmal ein foto wie als
hintergrundbild ja dann haben wir uns
ein bisschen im laden aufgehalten kommen
ein bisschen rum gespielt bisschen
fußball dies dass leute wert auf einmal
dieses symbol in der schule gemacht
jetzt müssen wir daran mag meint er kann
das nicht manchmal ohne dass ich darauf
machen
da habt ihr bock auf erfolg und diese
leute daran haben wirklich die airports
gekauft sie dann damit weg gelegt und
ich habe so gesagt ja eigentlich muss
ich denn jetzt airbus kaufen weil es ist
ja die idee hinter dem video das waren
die airports auf der passion also
eigentlich müsste ich als airports holen
ich muss ehrlich sagen mit airports kann
halt nicht jeder was anfangen nur leute
die apple haben von daher wollte ich
lieber irgendwas anderes und habe gesagt
okay du warst einfach noch
illegalen händlern auch mit anderen
dingen herum und machen dann so kann ich
jetzt kaufen die es normalerweise ist
die kasse und so muss es laufen keine
ahnung ich komme jetzt einfach airports
geschieht wenn die werden verlost
ihr kauft niemand was und eine von
inzwischen institutionen als baumhäuser
zeichnen dass man nebenbei wie man so
ein bisschen mit notwendig bezeichnet
runde geht es auch so der gestaltung
strategie wo steht das bauen wo
auszuwählen sollte es sein welche
materialien und sich dafür
und dann haben wir casten kennengelernt
wirklich super mitarbeiter cooler typ
wir haben uns mit dem lockt eine stunde
unterhalten der dann ist wirklich viel
erzählt und dann habe ich gedacht
stellte karsten doch einfach meine frage
eine frage
sie fragen was ihr als letztes verkauft
haben heute nichts weil wir machen
vor der pause haben wir das haben wir
kratzen wir sehen aber erstmals finden
die so ein bisschen langweilig aber dann
setzt wohl eher portion und hier habe
ich nach gefühl zwei stunden dann
wirklich ausverkauft du hast schon
welche
zudem verließ
haben sie nicht wahllos leute zwei
stunden später alter sonderrechte ewig
zu schwierig ich habe jetzt hier
airports geholt also ja ich hatte mir
auch eigentlich was anderes gewünscht um
ehrlich zu sein das hätte ihr gewünscht
also sondern campbell oder sogar schon
leicht gewesen weil airport kann ja
nicht jeder was man kommt also muss ja
sagt jay wilson als ob du da die
kaugummis dragées freund leute wir sind
jetzt nach also ich würde sagen uns ganz
schön und wir waren bestimmt jetzt in
diesem kaufhaus man über zwei stunden
oder ja und davon locker über eineinhalb
schon im apple store
also erstmal in diesem apple store wurde
es ja den du hast ja die ganze zeit
gesagt da waren so fünf kunden im
durchschnitt und 20 mitarbeiter wirklich
20 mitarbeiter oder ein neues team
überhaupt mir übertrieben des avant
alles voll mit mitarbeitern und wie
wurde es in einer tour
so kann man euch helfen so das ist ja
irgendwie nett aber ich mich auch voll
getränkt ist rein alles erkunden und
erst mal war das problem da hat niemand
was gekauft
irgendwann wurden dann die ersten
airports verkauft dann habe ich mal
gesagt habe so airports keine ahnung
könnte ich jetzt zu erholen aber das ist
jetzt nix also nichts besonderes so weiß
ich wollte irgendwie was was
außergewöhnliches haben
dann wurden die nächsten airports
verkauft und dann dachte ich so sind wir
mitarbeiter richtig cool ins gespräch
kommen carsten schöne größeren sollen
noch ein bisschen was war beim häuser
zeichnen erklärt und bisher wissen wir
so einen schnitt und dann habe ich so
gedacht kommen fragt was als erstes
verkauft hat ich musste schon fast an
doch dann habe ich einfach diese scheiß
heraus gekauft mit einer verpackung war
ok also das wort scheiße passt ja auch
nicht rein weißt du nur einfach weil ich
jetzt mir dachte so vielleicht gibt es
aber eben was anderes so was innovatives
meister beim airports kann auch nicht
jeder etwas anfangen können schon damit
was anfangen wenn sie lacht man kann
nicht verkaufen irgendwie seinen seinen
freund geschenkt aber wenn du kein
iphone hast kannst du mit airports ja
nichts anfangen trotzdem verlor sich die
natürlich an dieser stelle wieder
genauso wie den fernseher ein gefallen
jetzt nach hause ich habe
von technik gehört in den letzten zwei
stunden war die freude da wird also war
schon mal ganz unterhaltsam aber wir
hatten uns bestimmt er hat uns 10
verschiedene dinge erklärt in dieser
zeit nicht aber dass auch er der monster
auch gedacht haben so herre und du hast
so rüber gebracht so du willst es kaufen
aber das ist eigentlich komplett egal
wer willst du die testen einkauf einfach
so und schaut auf jeden fall beim marx
kanal vorbei in der video schreibung
verlinkt ist ein super channel
da geht's auch manchmal darum was die
freundin so oft im wald nennen die
finden biotest leute also ich bin wieder
zurück man muss sagen bei apple das
sieht schon immer sehr hochwertig außen
also höre mir diese tüte und das sind
jetzt die erfolgs geworden
also hier originale airport 180 euro lag
halt daran weil jeder heute airports
gekauft hat ich weiß nicht ob das immer
so ist heute warst du das so wenn ihr
sagt ich hätte folgt damit zu machen bei
dem gewinnspiel oder bei der verlosung
wie schon oft genug gesagt alles was ich
in dieser videoreihe kaufe werde ich
dann halt auch verlosen wir den
fernseher den kommentaren schon mal
eingebildet du hast gewonnen weil die
airports gewinns seht ihr den nächsten
video um daran teilzunehmen einfach
einen kommentar schreiben mit eurem
instagram account oder eure e mail oder
so damit ich euch kontaktieren kann und
den kanal abonnieren das war's dann
lasst mir sehr gerne auf 1 kommentar
wenn ihr sagt ja alex macht das
demnächst mal in dem oder dem laden und
dann machen wir das event
ansonsten schaut auf jeden fall auch
beim markt vorbei und wir sehen uns
sonntag oder so ich weiß nicht